welcome to the 29th ever episode of the
iced coffee hour with uh graham and jack
and so far this podcast has made 22
919 to date wow
both of you are naturals thank you you
did it your first did you practice that
at all i know
as opposed to taylor i didn't practice
at all yeah
that's amazing that's amazing well thank
you so much for agreeing to uh
come on the episode guys we got a very
interesting i feel like
i feel like uh maury povich
you are not the [ __ ] have you seen that
show oh yeah
maureen okay that's always my go-to
anytime i would stay home from
school i would sit there and secretly
watch mori my mom hated it
she would want me to watch nick jr and
then as soon as she would leave the room
i would turn it to like channel four i
think that was fan of the drama since
day one
i loved it yeah that was the original
but they delivered every time too they
started getting crazier and crazier
though for the views at the very end it
was just some nutty stuff but anyway
uh this episode we're going to be
confronting
jack's girlfriend
[Laughter]
someone should like i feel like either
one of you two should introduce
each other each other okay okay all
right
i can introduce you and even let me
finish confronting jack's girlfriend's
boyfriend
yeah i just got introduced yeah all
right well i'm taylor again i was on
i was a 27th ever episode guest um and
this is my boyfriend
alex welcome yeah that's me
i can go through the process of leading
up to this if you want yes
please do please do okay so
so basically when i was first uh on this
podcast the 27th ever episode
um graham sent me a dm because he
noticed one of my comments on his video
and he asked me if i wanted to come on
to the podcast and be
a blind date for jack a blind tinder
date you know i'm a subscriber i've
actually never downloaded
but that's okay um and
sorry um and i agreed of course and i
brought it to alex i said it's just
what did you think oh you you just sent
me the dm then like i've watched you for
many years so like
oh wow graham what does he want what
does he want but at the same time you
know when
uh when someone's sliding into your
girlfriend's dms
it kind of triggers like a fight or
flight response immediately so
i started like okay what does he want
and then i saw a blind date and so
immediately i was like oh okay are you
are you gonna what's what's going on
here right um
but then uh yeah you you said no no it's
probably just a concert for the show
and i was like oh yeah that of course
that that makes total sense
yeah because i figured you would have
asked me if i was single if it was
anything more
so that's that's where we arrived huh
yeah yeah so when i went into that i
just kind of assumed
i figured if it was like uh if you
weren't single you would say something
so we went in yeah all the scenarios
yeah right no but actually that was what
ultimately
pushed me over the edge because i was
like i mean surely he would ask if you
were single
if it was actually like a blind date and
like i i'd seen some episodes of the
show and i was like
yeah it's probably just going to be some
some quality click bait
and uh yeah that was my thought yeah see
my
my investigation ended i think i just
whatever instagram profile you linked on
your page
yeah that was what i just quickly did
this it was like all right
there we go i think we're safe and then
i brought up the data aspect and i think
well between the two
you got two chances no pictures on that
instagram profile and then
just throw it out there so i figured
between the two that's fair
because my my private instagram is
private okay you wouldn't have found it
yeah yeah yeah so i don't know
we talked about it and i figured i don't
know i figured it was a concept for the
show
so jack is a worthy adversary yeah
yeah no that's why i dressed up so you
know
i have something to prove well i hope
people are nice what i thought we would
do
and i didn't want to tell either of you
guys until right now but
like actually like just fighting it out
like jake paul just like a jake paul
right here right now
yeah yeah sure i'm kidding i'm kidding
so how did you guys meet
uh do you wanna yeah we met first day of
college
at penn and uh we were in the same class
called management 100 it's like all
wharton kids have to take it it's like a
fake consulting class
you're put in teams of 10 and then you
are given like um
a business in philly or like a club on
campus and they come to you for
consulting help and you help them with
their marketing and that kind of stuff
it's fake but i don't know it's a cool
class i guess but we were on the same
team
so we met first week of college we were
friends for a while and then yeah
and she couldn't stop staring at me
that's not true
you were staring at me so who asked to
uh you asked us taylor around or how did
this work
yeah i don't know it was pretty organic
kind of organic yeah
because this was a few years ago so pre
me too i had uh
two tickets to uh louis ck and uh i
don't even know if i asked you
explicitly
you kind of invited yourself i did not
invite myself i don't know
maybe i don't know it's so long ago i
know it's been it's been a minute but
yeah no we were just friends so it kind
of worked out organically yeah there was
no like romantic
climax this is uh
[Applause]
so you guys were in the same class
together and did you guys
sorry did you guys have a project
together yeah kind of
because we were on the same like
consulting team so we were given
it's like this it's interesting but yeah
i mean they stopped doing it now but
it's kind of like this pretentious thing
where
immediately once you start as a freshman
you act as like
a group of consultants for a non-profit
on campus
which sounds a lot cooler than it
actually is and like everyone pretty
much hated that class yeah
so how many how many years ago is this
or was it
yeah wow and so what's the plan because
you're planning to go to new york yes
so what's what's going to happen with
that so you work he works out of boston
okay so work from home now though work
from i mean he's yeah he's with me right
now in l.a but
once it's not work from home anymore
i'll be in new york he'll be in boston
got it it's not that far it's kind of
hard are you guys living together now
yeah yeah yeah peace with me and my
parents right now okay yeah in my
bedroom
how how does that work uh they get along
that's because everyone i talk to
they're like oh how are you getting
along with your
in-laws like essentially um and that
just works amazing yeah any complaints
it works great yeah because you're i
don't know
he's very chill he's easy like he's not
thank you you know but like
he's not like uh a nuisance in the house
i mean
i'm very biased but i think my parents
feel the same unloads a dishwasher he's
helpful around the house
but he works like 14 hours a day i am
the dishwasher man so you work from home
yes 14 hours in your bedroom okay corner
of her body corner off got it i have my
rona ranks set up with a bunch of
monitors yeah how do you bring that up
to your parents like hey
we're going to kind of move in here well
i so he
yeah part of this i just did yeah i know
the part of the reason is
part of the reason is because i mean
he's from sweden yeah so you wanted to
go home for a little while to work but
with travel restrictions it would be
kind of tough for you to get back in
um so it just kind of happened i
actually didn't really ask them
yeah he just came home after graduation
with me planning to stay for a few weeks
i guess and then figure it out um but
you couldn't really go home to sweden
and new york would have been kind of
weird
for you to i don't know you explained
yeah i mean
i mean that's it pretty much i mean i
mean because
i guess it's work from home everywhere
so like the alternative is either
i'm gonna work by myself in a studio in
boston
just not seeing anyone or like at her
place and at least see one person
so how long has that been for eight
months seven months um
since may since the end of day yeah okay
yeah since we graduated
got it and you do the chores yeah you
help her out yeah yeah yeah i tried
i tried to uh under promise and i would
deliver
i mean he offered to pay rent and stuff
my parents went okay yeah but yeah
kind of interesting set up not most
people have that but yeah yeah
no i'm gonna have your parents on next
oh that's that's gonna be that's gonna
be the next thing
confronting jack's
we should have your mom on it's the yeah
oh my god that would actually be
interesting
she's a very interesting character she
is yeah i told you guys a little bit
yeah did she
did she retired at 35 35 yeah yeah
so how funny would that be if we
actually get around the podcast
yeah we're getting a little ahead of him
a little bit yeah all right i mean let's
talk
let's talk about your parents what did
they think about this whole thing
yeah did you tell them about it and the
concept of it oh me coming on the show
in the first place
yeah my mom we like i said we talked
about all the scenarios like if it
actually was
meant to be more than a date like a yeah
what was that for the show what was your
plan for that
if it what happened i don't know
like what actually happened was my plan
if it were yeah like if you were to
actually ask me out i would be like oh
i actually have a boyfriend but um
that that was my plan i didn't think it
would i thought
i genuinely thought whether people
believe me or not i thought it was a
concept for the show or at least
i was convinced to think that so uh yeah
i don't know if that answers your
question that was my plan yeah sorry
andrew what what are your parents
oh yes yeah um they thought the same i
mean my dad
is protective so he just wanted to make
sure you guys were like normal cool
stranger yeah exactly um but i showed
them your channel
yeah they're interesting um and then my
mom thought the same as me she said oh
that'd be
awesome um kind of agreed she probably
thought it was concept for the show
but you're right now that you say that
because you didn't see my private
instagram but yeah that was my thought
process but they were cool with it yeah
yeah and you were on board the the
entire way were you ever apprehensive
i mean in the beginning i was yeah um
because i was like am i really
embarking on this path
i don't think you can put that on the
channel but yeah yeah we could you could
bleep that out
yeah yeah um
yeah no i mean at first i was like oh
are you sure you're gonna go through
with this
but like then i thought about it more
and more and actually it
it just seemed like it would be again
for the show
and um i really thought that like you
would have asked if she was single if it
was actually real
because yeah i mean because you don't
want to be put in a
situation where someone asks you
something and then you're the one oh
sorry i have a boyfriend that's the
whole thing
i didn't want to be presumptuous that
might sound stupid to you guys i don't
know
i don't know and but maybe this is like
maybe it's a guy thing i don't know
yeah a lot of guys get instinctually
moving close to the mic
yeah um no a lot of guys they uh
they don't like when girls are being
presumptuous when they try to be nice
even if they're flirting yeah
have you exp experienced that i haven't
but maybe i'm just
i don't really
so i was like okay do i i and i asked
you this too i said should i tell
grandma by the way i have a boyfriend or
is that being presumptuous because i
don't know if he's
assuming i don't or not yeah like all
these thoughts it was a very thought out
process
yeah which might sound weird i don't
want people to think that i i don't want
to just went on to
catfish jack yeah i really didn't that
was not my intention
yeah so to clear the air yeah basically
what happened was
she came over we filmed the podcast i
hadn't talked to her we hadn't
i really have exchanged very few words
with her before we started filming yeah
then we finished and then graham was
like he told me he said
i was trying to win okay so we actually
let's let's go into the details here
okay so before you came over
graham said this he said okay we're
going to come up with a code word
if you want to go to dinner with her
afterwards porcupine
no what was it well do you remember the
go-to yeah so it was
um you should have done like a sign yeah
it was
uh do you want to download the footage
tonight
that was that was the code okay so we
always say that though every night yeah
so it's night or tomorrow yeah so he
told me he's like okay so i'm going to
ask you this and if you say yes
that means you want to go like to dinner
with her or whatever and if you say no
that means that you don't what'd you say
he didn't ask me you ended up not even
asking no we spent like
five ten minutes agreeing that that was
going to be the code word i forget and
you didn't even use it
i forget you didn't you literally just
you just
you left and then you and then you're
like okay go go ask her out
and you left and then i don't know that
was it that's what i was on the phone
by the way i wouldn't be offended if you
didn't if the answer was no
oh no it's okay okay um so you were in
the bathroom told me that he said okay
now is your like your chance now's the
time exactly so he's like okay so i'm
gonna go
over and like talk with macy okay and
then he leaves and i'm just standing
here at this table
and i'm kind of just like twiddling my
thumbs right we talked for a few minutes
we talked for a few minutes but i knew
it was so hard to to muster up that
courage but it's okay
it's okay and i said so would you like
to go to dinner
and then you said okay uh i have a
boyfriend
and this is after we filmed the entire
podcast episode
and uh and obviously like i was i was
like okay that's totally fine yeah like
i was very very shocked and i laughed
because i thought it was just funny
like the whole situation was just it is
hilarious i thought you seemed relieved
that's the vibe i got because jack
didn't want to pay for dinner that's a
good
time no no no not that at all like it
was
i was maybe a little bit relieved
because it was just like less stressful
yeah you said you're nervous
i was nervous too i was so nervous yeah
i was really nervous yeah and uh that
was basically what happened i said you
want to go to dinner and then she said
she said i have a boyfriend and then i
just i laughed and i was like you didn't
laugh
i didn't you know you did oh
so that was it i just laughed and i was
like that's totally okay i was like
that's that's totally fine
like i'm so sorry oh my god no i mean
i'm sorry i felt bad afterwards
yeah no taylor came back and she was
like i was rattling they actually
thought
that you know that they might have
thought it was an actual blind date
like yeah she was like down for several
days after
oh actually i thought you were oh yeah i
thought you weren't going to air the
episode after that
no no it was
it was a good episode it was but yeah i
went into it thinking like
we're actually going to get like a blind
date it might not be a tinder date but
like
close enough yeah you know yeah yeah
well i mean i don't i can't see you
having problems getting a date
it's so hard for you i'm not just saying
that like you you need to tell me you go
on tinder and you don't get a date well
i mean i i like people will match with
me but i just like
i i just don't i don't know maybe i
don't follow through
but i'm just kind of sick of like on the
dating apps a lot of the times like
you have a lot of conversation with
someone and then they kind of just like
leave out of nowhere and i
got so tired of that happening over and
over and over again yeah that i would
just like i would send a paragraph i'm
like hey
look like i'm just like i'm new to the
area like i'm just looking to meet
people like even if nothing comes out of
it yeah
like let's just like meet up go get some
food we could go for a walk by the beach
or whatever
and it's i think that it's just like
definitely has a lower success rate if
you don't talk to them beforehand but i
also don't really want to waste my time
like right
okay that's you know i know it's a
better way to put it but like yeah that
happened so many times where i just felt
like i was wasting my time yeah
opportunity costs yeah it was just
it was exactly yeah you might as well
make videos yeah yeah
because nothing usually came out of
those right so that makes sense and i
think now it definitely drastically
lowered my chances of actually seeing
anyone
like that what no but by like shortening
it up and just saying
something like the paragraph because i
don't know this guy you can't do that no
i know i shouldn't do it yeah now you
just do this 3 am you up texas
no i definitely do like man it's like
you're just spoiling the end of a movie
that's what it is no it's not yes it is
i would way rather get to know them in
person
then you just you just sending a text
saying hey new to the area want to meet
up take a walk in the beach
that is you essentially spoiling the end
of the movie
how what does that even mean because
you're you're not building up to
anything
ideally what there should be is some
sort of conversation they need to fill
you out a little bit see what your
personality's like
see how can i assure you but you know
your text you can
it's just in the way that you convey
messages
to this channel no i could i would never
i would never yeah
no really it's it's you need to to
i don't want to say entice them in such
a way but you you have to
warm things up a little bit and that's
only done through conversation you
if you were just i guaranteed half the
people you were just going to say hey
let's go meet up on the beach
i don't say that yeah i know i know but
if you started off small
you build off of something you have some
back and forth
and then after like a day you go and ask
something like that you're gonna have a
much higher success rate
let me rephrase it's not my first
message like i exchanged
two three messages but then i'm just
over it like every single conversation
is the same hey
how are you what are you up to today
that's it and then it's like where do
you go from there
so you know what i mean like i feel like
it's so much easier to get to know
someone in person
than it is over text because what
changes up a text conversation
nothing it's just wherever you take it
right whereas if you meet someone in
person
like there's so much more to to talk
about so much more to do
whereas the text conversation is just
purely upon the
the letters that you write right you
don't even know it's true
so what do you guys think about this
yeah no you got it what is your i
honestly what is your name alex
we're gonna have to go back i mean in
person i said this is alex when we
walked in but you were busy doing
something this would be an editing job
for you
okay let's see alex up here yeah
what do you think about this i mean
you've been on tinder so
yeah explain no but you gotta you gotta
make sure your first message is kind of
like a like a thumbnail for a video
yeah yeah that's a good way you can't
use analogy you can't just give away all
these are so stressful dude like i'm not
suck man they do know
you spend so much time on thumbnails you
guys do yeah in a good way but like
you still have you know you have to you
have to entice them say something like
uh there are five secrets that the
government doesn't want you to know
and they'll be like oh wow like i don't
i don't know yeah uh but i know what
you're saying like it's kind of like the
storytelling too i think about this a
lot on my channel is like
don't just drop the bomb at first not
that you are dropping bombs in the
beginning but
lead up to it somehow but i also know
what you're saying because if it that
leads to
like a dead so many times and it feels
like a waste of time i get that but you
know what i feel like you might be
getting to a sticking point
like you get to a certain point and then
let's say five steps in
then it drops off i i'd say your time
would be best spent improving that fifth
step
wherever that is you see the drop off
that's the point to spend your time
you have to have like a straight line
system like drawing yeah but for tender
yeah okay like for videos like this is
difficult
okay i'm being completely honest i'm
trying okay
i need like a representation of this so
if
you or you or you anyone were to strike
up conversation with someone else
via text text is different than in
person yes so i would usually just say
hey how are you
yeah what do you like what are you doing
today like um
no because because that doesn't convey
any that doesn't show any personality
um say something funny yeah yeah like
open with a little i'm not a joke
necessarily but like a cheeky
what up mama no all right i don't know
i mean anything that might work yeah you
can see their photos right
yeah well of course yeah you can see
their photos make some pick something
out of their photo and maybe make a
cheeky comment about yeah
i don't know their dog you're a cute dog
i think like 95
of people who use tinder anyway are just
doing it for validation so
i don't know just going with a should i
be on like a harmony instead or
something no
i'm only 22. dude farmers only farmers
only exactly
i was going to say well no locals
started a bunch of like luxurious dating
websites back in the day maybe some of
those are still i don't think i'm there
yet
yeah but really quick we have a word
from our sponsor nordvpn
nordvpn provides a virtual private
network or vpn service to protect your
data when you're online now this is the
way that your internet probably
currently works you type something into
your connected device
that information goes to your local net
aka router
it then exits and then goes to the
internet it's then directed to the
server of the website that you requested
information from
and finally it gets sent back to your
computer some of these channels that the
information travels through
can be unprotected networks and the bad
people can take this information from
you
this information that is stolen could be
as bad as credit card information
or as simple as your ip address which is
basically just showing where you're
connecting from
what nordvpn does is encrypt the
information that you're sending
so it can't be picked up by those bad
guys when you're sending it off to the
servers
kind of like using harry potter's
invisibility cloak it will also hide
your ip address and also restrict your
internet service provider from seeing
which domains you're accessing because
let's be honest
sometimes we don't want spectrum to know
what websites we're connecting to
and all in all when it comes to cyber
security especially in this day and age
you can never be too careful so if you
want to protect yourself online
make sure to check out nordvpn because
they are having a special
christmas sale check out nordvpn.com
ich to get four months free when you
purchase a two-year plan
yes you heard me right check out
nordvpn's two-year plan to get
four months free with their christmas
sale and with that said you guys back to
the podcast
let's say alex yes you saw
taylor on a dating website um okay and
you saw her profile
it's not so much like match.com but he
said dating website
on a dating network yeah what would you
what would you send to her without
knowing me
take your time think this through
because like you would have time
honestly i think most of it just comes
down to
like pure numbers like like it's a
numbers game
yeah yeah so like there's no way like an
individual
girl is you know you can't be sure that
she's gonna
wanna even respond because a lot of
girls especially
are like i said they're on for
validation so like they have no
intention of doing it but like
who doesn't feel good just like going on
this app and see oh wow all these guys
think i'm so pretty
um so i would just uh not overthink it
and just like realize she's probably
gonna say no are you telling him to
swipe right on everybody
no uh numbers maybe
i don't know you know what it was gonna
thought this through funny story time
but a buddy of mine uh he anthony if
you're watching this
i'm gonna mention you here um uh
was on tinder and wasn't getting many
matches
so he's just like what if i just change
my profile to be a girl
and let's just see what i get the number
of
matches was insane
it was to the point where his phone was
like overheating and shutting down
oh my god because of how many matches he
was getting
and then uh i don't know if i want to
say this but um
[Music]
we saw we saw girls on tinder putting
their venmo
uh-huh so people could send them money
so i said to him
what if you just put your venmo and we
could see how much money you
make and he made money oh my goodness
are you gonna you need to i need to make
a video confronting a scammer
man
no because he got so many matches
something happened yeah i think he was
swiping too much or something happened
but he actually got his account taken
down
gotcha yeah before you was it on the
podcast with andre where you talked
about before
macy of course you were on tinder and
didn't you like edit a little blue thing
gosh yeah yeah for the super like thing
yeah yeah
the thumbnail that's all it is
like picture here's another tip from uh
teron alex
tinder consulting llc free of charge um
you have to look from the perspective of
the girls that are swiping on you
and if you see girls swiping on tinder
it looks like this
they're all swiping left and most guys
have like low resolution
pictures so having just a high
resolution picture will make
girls go oh wow something different
let's at least
look at what this man has to offer and
not just swipe left immediately yeah
you know what would be so much better is
if if it tinder allowed for video
just a five second like hey what's up
don't don't don't smoke
hey my name's graham sorry something
like that would be really cool
clickbaity yeah if any tinder people are
watching this
try that that would be in it imagine if
someone started that up of just
video just five second be good
that would be good yeah pitch it yeah
cut this out and pitch it
to them that would be a good idea no
i'll i'll leave it up if if anyone gets
rich off this just
just give me like ten percent give him
something give me something give me five
percent of it yeah
that would be a great idea i've just you
swipe on like little videos yeah like a
little tick tock
thing yeah that would be cool or gifts
have you ever considered doing like um
podcast highlights yeah yeah we thought
about it
uh we're too small for that right now
once we get 100 000 subscribers we will
jr eclipse that's all i watch yeah we
have a tick tock though
all day long we have an iced coffee hour
tick tock where we take clips
and uh those are doing well on tick tock
shout out to aiden
he edits those yeah thank you uh but
those are doing really well
but youtube i think it's too early to
start doing that oh so what are you
doing
i'm not on tick tock the iced coffee
hour they take clips like this
put them in 60 seconds and then just
repost them to tick tock like like the
best 60 second clip
of of whatever we're talking about uh
and then my own personally is
[Music]
random my friend saw the one of me uh
and send it to me i think i told you
oh they'll take thoughts yeah oh wow
yeah some of these
some of these got a lot of views what's
that one like five hundred thousand
views
a couple of them about like half a
million yeah oh wow some people like
that i know
too they've discovered me from tick tock
not from youtube
like from the iced coffee hour i'm not
saying that this channel is like
super big or anything but like i would
have expected if they would have found
me from tech hockey it would be from
this
youtube right yeah yeah huh interesting
interesting
oh that's a question i was going to ask
you i'm doing nowadays yeah
would you um i'm sure you've had girls
reach out like via youtube
in the comments like trying to go on a
date on occasion but i think that
there's a weird dynamic to those
relationships
if they reach out like oh i see we mean
you know what i mean reaching out for
perhaps the wrong reason
no no just that like they
know me you know or they know of me oh
and you don't know that
yeah it's just like an odd dynamic why
so what they're interested in the same
things as you
true i mean i like i felt like i knew
you guys you didn't know
yet but when i saw you it was so weird
because i felt like
i knew you yeah yeah and it was so weird
because like i introduced myself and you
said oh hi graham and it like
intuitively it felt like wait what's up
you guys it's graham here yeah yeah
you know what you said it's like yeah we
know each other yeah like wait what are
we doing here
yeah yeah i felt the same way that's how
i felt with other people i met from
youtube
and even some of my like now i would
consider like my best friends i've met
from youtube uh like jeremy
financial education is one of those guys
uh we talked online for like a year
maybe a year and a half before meeting
yeah and then meeting in person
like the first minute was awkward
because it's like i'm so used to seeing
him just on a little screen and now like
oh he's
he's tall way taller than i expected
but after like a minute it was just like
we're best friends yeah after that
right same with a lot of these people
that i that i've met
from youtube is just you you instantly
hit it off because you already know each
other so you could cut all the stuff
so jack i think that's that's the way
you should look at it it's like you're
getting people
who already know what you're about
they're interested in the same topics
and you could weed out
everybody who's not interested in that
it's it's it's probably the the most
efficient way
you could go about doing this if you're
talking about efficiency not wasting
time we have a very low demographic of
women 15 20 you can't tell me at a 20
there's not the perfect person out there
who's watching the podcast right now and
be like
jack i'm next yeah how many subscribers
60 000.
69. is it actually 69
wow yeah
yeah yeah that 169 420 kind of yeah yeah
but seriously that that's gotta be like
12 000 women at that point not to
mention
and those are only the ones who
subscribed yeah what about dms on
instagram
you must get slid into it happens
definitely it happens like on occasion
yeah you respond sometimes not usually
no why not because i mean i'm sitting
here and you're
i mean you have 12 000 girls looking up
to you
okay i don't know how many guys back
home might be like
thousands of girls that is over i hate
that very large overstatement but you
have some
some yeah yeah even if it's one percent
of that all i'm saying is this is
they're in
they're into the same stuff they know
what you're about they already know your
personality
you've already talked about yourself
here so now
yeah maybe i will be open to it all
right cool close that off good yes
nice okay you gotta put up your
instagram right now jls
selby jls selfie
thanks graham what's the ls part my
middle name and my last name oh
jls selby okay yeah yeah what's your
middle name
lloyd lloyd yeah wait why is there two
s's
j l s selby yeah
yeah i honestly don't know why it has
two s's maybe it was taken
or something but that's just what i've
rolled with since i was a kid jls
[Music]
i know gp stefan right like yeah g
stefan
there was i think it was taken g stefan
was taken so i had to do g
gps stefan
you should you know we should have
matching arms you should change yours to
gps stephanie that would be something
how much would it be to like buy a
domain name expenses instagram
depends what you want to buy so i've
seen some where they have this
hack where people who know someone else
at like instagram
apparently what some of these people do
is they'll pay like five to ten thousand
dollars
and in if an account hadn't posted in
like three to four years
instagram allegedly has the power to go
in and take that username from them if
it's an inactive account of like a few
years
so you have to know someone on instagram
to be able to do that and they'll charge
a few grand to like 10 grand to do that
i've also seen some people
sell usernames i think someone tried to
sell me gram
and it was like 20 grand and i figured
there's no way i'm paying 20 000
for gram and then the person who took
the username graham
sent me a dm let's let's see if i can
send the dm because i asked them how
much they paid for that
and i think they paid more than what i
was offered which is crazy but
they should have paid for it honestly
did they do that
it sounded like they were trying to flip
your name like you would a house
yeah oh yeah
you're curious so yeah sorry so it was
twenty thousand dollars the username
that was it
but that's it uh he has the account
uh cowbelly yeah graham what honestly
20 000 i don't know about names or
anything but i feel like
just having to handle graham is pretty
powerful that's a good name yes
there's a price to that like i wouldn't
mind paying like five grand
how much would you pay for just well
jack for jack i think
jack is different than the greatest is
like the most common name yeah yeah what
would you pay for graham
i would not pay not nearly as much as i
probably should well
my name was graham yeah what would you
what would you pay what would you want
me
if my name was grant yes in my situation
what would you tell
my money my situation how much should i
pay for graham
i would have paid 20 000 you really
would have yeah i think why
just having to handle gram especially on
instagram
i know for a fact that instagram is
continuing to grow
and like i just think that having a
handle like that is just like crazy
especially since like now people are
like
having absurd handles because
everything's been taken yeah that's true
in the grand scheme of things too like
20k to be like as soon as someone
searches for graham
yeah yeah i don't know just like seo
maybe you dropped the ball but but no
but it still comes up when you type in
gram it's a cf7 gram
s um the other thing was that i've just
been advertising gp stefan for such a
long time on like hundreds of videos
that i was worried
switching to graham like what would that
do to all my past videos
but it would be really cool to say like
add me on instagram
gram yeah yeah like that would be really
cool i would pay maybe like 10
for it what so it went up a little bit
five times yeah it went up
you gotta buy it before this airs yeah
they're gonna price gouge you yeah
no the guy's already bought it yeah but
you can buy it again yeah
yeah but he already knows my offer is
tent so if he wants to
get it back someone else jack i mean i
don't know
we have we could do what's in your
wallet segment oh yeah let's see let's
see
yeah let's do what's in your wallet um
let me grab my phone i don't care about
it
look like guys oh yeah can we just
straight up
like look through your stuff yeah all
right cool let me just
let me just make sure no no no you're
gonna like this no you can't look
through it
okay you can't look through that's
that's more than that should i tell my
health insurance
no that's actually kind of funny no it's
fine so i got your wallet
do you see how used that is yeah i do
this is my wallet all right let's see
i'm frugal oh wow
and then all of this health insurance
and then like
all right so where should we start so
your wallet is uh
in the back of your phone yes that's
really neat and what do we got here we
got uh emergency
emergency card in case that's smart yeah
so i don't have that
i don't think you have to but yeah it's
good to have a guess on that that's cool
my mom's like yeah if you're ever in an
emergency you can be like emergency card
okay we got a bed
like a bank of america cash rewards card
that's a good credit card i have that
one too
cool health card okay yeah oh i hate
this one
i hate wells fargo no i can't stand them
sorry and then
uh id okay i should get it we're not
expired
oh yeah mine's expired your ideas yeah
really
yeah that's not good yeah dmv has been
closed all right so what's this so we
got
yeah that's a very worn wallet how long
have you had this for
five years that's i think yeah that's a
pen wallet right yeah it's a pen wallet
did you get it for free
yes it was actually given to me how many
cards do you have in here
uh i mean they're not credit cards can i
can i oh [ __ ]
okay let's see it's a big fat stack
cards oh i mean no
no that's just because i haven't thrown
them all away
you still have your okay yeah i haven't
seen your cards it's good actually to
have your student id
in some cases oh my god so how many
access cards do you have a starbucks
what's that
karen hates you now oh a gift card
exactly yeah we should use it i think i
signed up for like dashlane or something
all right all right so we got a
starbucks card a lot a lot of student
ids
mcdonald's gift card that's pretty good
oh you have one of these
a tile those things are good that's
smart i bought that for
saying like you can just go into a store
and get a new one for free or something
but i
just didn't do it yeah we approve of the
wallets yeah thanks thank you guys not
bad you were asking me though to switch
topics here for a second about the two
dollar bills
yes so who was it was it was it ryan
pinita
i can't remember it's either i saw it on
tick tock or i saw
or ryan pinit was telling me about this
of
uh going to the bank and getting two
dollar bills and it makes you very
memorable
anytime you're gonna tip with a two
dollar bill they'll never forget you or
if you just have two dollar bills you
happen to pay in two dollar bills it's
you could go to the bank you get these
at face value so i went to the bank
five hundred dollars with the two dollar
bills jack took 200 of it so i got 300
and two dollar bills and they're just
cool like you came in here and you
thought like what i thought they were
right so it's just it's cool it's a it's
a really interesting talking piece
that's free you just go to the bank you
ask them for two dollar bills you get a
whole bunch and they look cool like this
and that's it and just tip people with
two dollar bills graham and i were at
the bank when he was getting these
and i heard him ask like the teller if
he can have any two dollar bills so i
got out of the church cooking i ran over
and i was like can i get a couple as
well yeah and he was like yeah sure
and then she was like all right how many
do you want and he's like um
500 worth a thousand dollars worth and
uh and i was like
oh my god i thought you were gonna get
like 10. no
gosh now you go big what i ask is how
many do you have
yeah you literally asked that yeah yeah
and she's like we have as many as you
want yeah so that made me feel so good i
have as many as i want
yeah yeah you were out so i think i said
a thousand i think i know you said 500
and then i said can i get a couple and i
heard you say
oh i want 500 and then i ran over and i
said like oh can i have someone you like
make it a thousand and i was like oh my
god i don't need 252
bills but you never know but here's the
thing
it's it's uh it's cash so if you need to
take it back to the bank you can
get a thousand bucks it's cool play
around with it a little bit
put it back in the bank yeah think of
all the thumbnails we could do with this
two dollar bills so anyway
i i think it's neat i would recommend
everyone go to the bank get two dollar
bills like this
it's neat it's cool it's a fun talking
piece if you tip anybody
with a two dollar bill they're never
gonna forget you true and i and i agree
with that
so that's my two dollar bill story
everyone should go to yeah
my two dollars yeah you guys is there
anything that you guys want to talk
about for
retail anything you want to clear the
air anything like that clear the air
[ __ ]
ask any questions talk to the viewers
about of course
my channel you know i've already
i mean again thank you guys so much for
having me on the first time i've seen so
much growth it's crazy
it's really cool it's gonna happen at
some point yeah thank you
um that's been awesome yeah what is it
like for you to meet jack
uh oh i was sizing him up
the very first moment i walked into the
door um yeah no it's fine
what was the overall like reaction like
really
i mean obviously i know that like you
got some subscribers and
views and stuff but like what about like
like dms
comments like i didn't really go through
like reading any comments or anything no
of course
uh very positive overwhelmingly positive
i thought that because i missed
questions on the quiz people would like
come for me if you did but like
uh in a couple things that i overthought
like on my way home after the podcast i
was like people are gonna
you know whatever but it was so positive
people were so
nice about i don't know they said nice
things and like
said i seemed like i knew you guys
beforehand and it seemed like we were
just friends talking so
um and a lot of new subscribers but also
ones on my latest video
that said like you know graham brought
me here you kept me here which like is
the nicest compliment i feel like i
could have received because i figured i
would
lose subscribers after i started
reposting i mean posting my my normal
content but
it's still growing yeah and everyone's
so nice and some constructive criticism
that i've taken
um to heart like really nice stuff
though and then you know a couple
dm's that whatever i'm gonna get anyway
but i was also surprised at like how
positive ever like i was ready to roll
up my sleeves yeah getting back at the
internet
everyone everyone watches the channel is
so positive yeah
everyone is and they're very supportive
so thank you guys yeah thank you best
fans
yes no but that's true is that people
that came to my channel from here
they're like your biggest fans and i
mean the creme de la creme yes
and what about the negative ones it got
a few um
someone told me i dishonored wharton by
missing a
couple questions uh which is what i felt
like too but
what else did i get i got a couple um um
didn't i didn't
i want to like buy your used underwear
whoa why are you serious yeah
yeah are you serious yeah can we get it
can we see the dm it was actually on
poshmark
even your cousin reached out to me on
poshmark um oh malaya
mm-hmm oh yeah i got people like
because i sell on poshmark people came
and looked at my closet and yeah and
wrote like oh you're such a i don't know
yeah you represent the community well
nice things you know but yeah someone
did ask me like how much for your used
panties
wow i will say it before the podcast
i've gotten
i mean i mean that wasn't someone
necessarily from the gym
yeah no we're thinking like actually
negative ones there were a few
um i don't um i mean for some of them
it's like
hard to it's kind of hard because like
they
might mean well but like the tone and
the comment just comes off super off
like they can start off like i don't
mean to be uh like offensive
and then they have like and they're
being super offensive yeah even though
there's
like a grain of truth right right like i
don't know
we've also talked about like yeah at
what point does
constructive criticism like turn into
just a troll
right and it's like a person it's very
hard to just like dismissively say oh
that's just a troll
because uh that person was a troll we
hate him
yeah but no overwhelmingly positive good
yeah well thank you guys
thank you guys yeah thanks thanks to all
the subscribers now don't thank me
since you guys watching yeah of course
of course yeah of course
yeah yeah but i guess thank you for
being a positive role model because
that's
part of the reason that you got my
subscribers thank you for sure
actually that sounds making me look good
yeah so that's true
yeah yeah do you guys have any other
things you want to talk about
i guess worrying about getting hate
because i know some people won't believe
that i
my intention was not to like catfish you
or anything which it wasn't but i get
how people won't believe that
yeah i mean looking back like it might
seem obvious but like at the time like
we genuinely
i thought it was a funny thing it was
just like a concert for the show and
again like after after she
she came home and realized that like you
know maybe it wasn't
like i thought you hated me i thought
you had you do things
for real on the channel you hated it
because one oh she did
she hates me i thought graham was
disappointed because you were trying to
wingman your friend which
was very nice well i was a little bit
disappointed
yeah i won't lie trying to wingman jack
yeah we do things for real on the
channel
so we don't stay with you no no nothing
is staged nothing you ever see a stage
well now i know
but yeah but i felt i just please
believe i felt really bad because when i
got home i mean i really was
i was rattled my mom's like how did it
go well all of you guys were like how'd
it go i said
i don't know like i felt like the
conversation was good but then at the
end it was spoiled because i
anyway i don't need to go over that but
um what was i talking about yeah no i
thought you hated me
no no because one when i said when i
hadn't said i had a boyfriend
you seemed relieved which is fine like i
didn't feel offended that you seemed
relieved but i thought
you didn't want to like i was only
really like in that moment it was a
really stressful situation for me yeah
like no
i i was i was not upset i actually wish
that we were just filming
during that moment i got that and then
like definitely like i was relieved
because it was such a stressful and like
an intense
thing for me to do and then like
afterwards i was like oh i don't even
have to worry about it anymore right you
know
and then like i feel like a couple days
later i was kind of like
i like i was a little more iffy on it
like i was like oh that is like a little
weird or whatever
like definitely made me feel a little
off but then like a few days after that
then i was just like oh
like whatever like i i see where you're
coming from and i understand that like
if someone like graham reached out to me
and i had you know hadn't known him or
whatever
um i would definitely like i could see
where you're coming from
how you responded that i thought it
would be presumptuous for me to say like
yeah yeah of course like which might
sound stupid to you but that really is
no i i totally understand it so i don't
know yeah
it's anyway like for those no like
for those who are listening like this is
a weird thing to say but
i can't really for me personally it's
difficult for me to catch feelings for
someone
with but i only have known them for like
what was that like an hour yeah on
camera too so that was
that was not me like expressing the fact
that like i like you or anything it was
me more so just thinking like
i would i would be okay like getting to
know you and seeing
you know what i mean yep 100 and that's
the other thing too if we
have a date on the show there is going
to be that pressure
jack what happened how'd the day go how
did they go oh you guys aren't seeing
each other anymore what happened
tell us tell us you get a bit of that
too yeah how did
how did you feel about that getting all
those comments because i still see him
uh okay so like it has to go with
everything is so weird so like all those
comments and everything like how is it
with taylor whatever
for the most part i would say like uh
there's like a video coming soon all
right like
that's good that's a good response find
out or whatever i would say like
oh for a couple i said like there have
been developments
because i didn't know
yeah i never have i basically said i
didn't say the same but i use this emoji
all the time like the
um right like how's it going with jack
the shrug exactly i have
a shortcut in my phone when i write
shrug anyway it does this one
yeah i've been responding that to people
to like keep the fun going because they
seem invested and
you were i mean you agree just keep the
secret going or not the secret but that
sounds
stupid you know what i mean yeah you
don't want to be the bearer of bad news
then
okay for alex yeah did that
i i i feel like if i was in your
position i would feel like a little bit
weird
because obviously like your girlfriend
is handcuffed like there's nothing that
she could really do
and then like you're kind of just like
you know alongside her while people are
asking that about like a different man
yeah yeah and you don't want to step in
and be like no you're going to do this
you guard her
shut up shut up guys
just dislike all of this yeah
yeah no that's what i do no i don't care
i don't know you're pretty confident in
our
no go ahead um yeah no no i
i yeah i don't i don't know i don't take
it to uh
did it hard for you at all not really um
should it have maybe yeah i don't know
it's just like random people on the
internet i don't it's a testament to the
strength
yeah my mental fortitude that's been a
while
you and me like we've been dating for a
while if a comment like that would break
us up that's
that's saying something oh yeah i mean i
can see why why
would no way but people yeah but um
yeah no i mean it's just like random
people on the internet respect
yeah so anything else you want to say
you got you got one camera there
here's a we'll wrap up here anything
else you want to say to the audience
right there in that camera
i just want to say thank you for having
me on the podcast and
clearly let us uh clear the air yeah and
i hope i was close enough to the mic
i feel like you're gonna have to cut
like half of what i said out no but uh
yeah yeah but thank you the people that
went over to taylor's channel were
awesome like overwhelmingly awesome i
was so surprised me too oh i wasn't
surprised because no i was
yeah yeah um yeah yeah thank you guys
for watching
thank you guys again for having me on um
yeah and for people that came over to my
channel again thank you for being so
positive i really appreciate it it
actually means so much
i yeah i've gone on and on about my
channel or on my channel saying
how nice everyone was so thank you yeah
comment
like subscribe subscribe to taylor's
channel thank you and
um get your four free stocks down below
in the description
i don't know if the offer is going to be
expiring if you if you click on the link
and you still see the offer there
get it because they told me it was going
to end like any day now but they've kept
it going now past
november 30th so if you get it if you
see it down below in the description
just get that offer immediately weeble
weeble yeah
so four free stocks four free stocks or
three songs it was three before yeah it
was three now it was two
it was two before that yeah for a while
it was one they keep pumping it
but i think they gotta go back down they
can't continue to afford
this sort of level of money it's
expensive people are getting like 20
bucks now worth of free stock so just
get it down below in the description
thank you so much for watching and until
next time
okay and then how much is the podcast
made
yeah i'm pretty sleep deprived so i
don't know if i can remember all this
you're good
you got it oh was it 22 22 now that
keeps 919.
you're going to be looking in that
camera that one is just on you guys this
is on all of us and this is just done
so ignore that i was gonna do something
like that yeah yeah so
cool okay uh i'm gonna screw this up
it's fine
uh